COMPARE, DIFFICULT TO MEASURE,
DIFFICULT TO ADDRESS.
>> ALINA BESKROVNA IS A START-UP
DEVELOPER WHO RECENTLY ESCAPED
THE BESIEGED CITY OF MARIUPOL.
SHE IS WITH US FROM WARSAW,
POLAND.
SO GLAD TO SEE YOU SAFELY OUT.
YOU WERE, I UNDERSTAND,
SHELTERING FOR 28 DAYS IN
MARIUPOL.
TELL US ABOUT WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCED THERE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
I'M GLAD TO BE ABLE TO TELL MY
STORY TO THE WORLD.
YES, I WAS IN MARIUPOL WHEN THE
WAR BEGAN ON THE 24th OF
FEBRUARY, AND I ESCAPED
MIRACULOUSLY WITH MY MOTHER ON
THE 23rd OF MARCH.
WE STAYED IN THE BASEMENT THE
ENTIRE TIME, AND THE AIR RAIDS
PICKED UP ABOUT MARCH 8th TO
MARCH 9th.
THERE WAS CONSTANT SHELLING.
WE DID NOT HAVE ANY ELECTRICITY,
ANY HEATING, ANY WATER
WHATSOEVER, AND WE FOUND
OURSELVES MELTING SNOW JUST TO
HAVE SOMETHING TO DRINK, COOKING
ON OPEN-AIR FIRES UNDER
SHELLING, CONSTANTLY DECIDING
BETWEEN STAYING HUNGRY OR TRYING
TO MAKE SOME FOOD UNDER FIRE.
THERE WAS NO CELL PHONE SERVICE,
NO WI-FI OBVIOUSLY, AND I
WITNESSED A LOT OF CIVILIAN
DEATHS AND JUST MAKESHIFT GRAVES
BY THE SIDES OF THE ROADS.
>> I MEAN JUST LISTENING TO YOU
DESCRIBE WHAT YOU WENT THROUGH
IS SO UPSETTING, ALINA, AND I'M
SO SORRY YOU WENT THROUGH THIS.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE IN THAT
SHELTER, IN THAT BASEMENT?
WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH YOUR
MIND?
HOW WERE YOU ABLE TO WITHSTAND
THIS ANGUISH PSYCHOLOGICALLY?
YOU WERE WITH YOUR MOTHER, I
UNDERSTAND.
>> YES.
I WAS WITH MY MOTHER, AND I WAS
WITH MY THREE CATS THAT I JUST
COULD NOT LEAVE BEHIND.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT IT
WASN'T A PROPER SHELTER.
IT WAS JUST A BASEMENT, AND WE
WERE VERY LUCKY BECAUSE IT WAS
TECHNICALLY LUXURIOUS
ACCOMMODATION BECAUSE IN MY
BASEMENT, WE WERE ABLE TO STAND
UP, UPRIGHT, AND IT WAS DRY
UNLIKE IN MOST BASEMENTS IN
MARIUPOL THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO
STILL ENDURE AS WE SPEAK.
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY PITCH DARK
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
ELECTRICITY.
WE USED CANDLES.
WE SPOENTENT MOST OF OUR TIME TG
TO SURVIVE, BETWEEN TRYING TO
GET WATER AND COOKING FOOD AND
RATIONING AND THINKING HOW MUCH
MORE WE CAN MAKE IT IN THIS
BESIEGED CITY AS THERE WAS NO
WAY TO GET FOOD.
MONEY WAS WORTHLESS, YOU KNOW.
WE WERE JUST THINKING OF HOW DO
WE ESCAPE, AND THEN HOW DO WE
LIVE WITH MAKING IT THROUGH IF
WE DO ESCAPE SUCCESSFULLY,
KNOWING SO MANY PEOPLE ARE JUST
LEFT BEHIND IN THOSE CONDITIONS?
>> AND YOU HAVE THAT GUILT OF
LEAVING PEOPLE BEHIND.
HOW WERE YOU EVEN FINDING FOOD
TO EAT?
>> WE COOPERATED WITH NEIGHBORS
JUST BECAUSE IT WAS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO SURVIVE ON YOUR
OWN.
SO WE POOLED ALL OUR STASHED
RESOURCES TOGETHER, YOU KNOW.
EVERYONE WENT THROUGH THEIR
CUPBOARDS AND KITCHEN CABINETS,
POOLED IT ALL TOGETHER, TRIED TO
MAKE IT THROUGH TOGETHER.
BUT IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT ONCE THE
GROCERY STORES WERE LOOTED AND
THERE WAS A THRIVING BLACK
MARKET, YOU KNOW, THE MORE
VULNERABLE YOU ARE, MAYBE THE
ELDERLY, MAYBE YOU DID NOT THINK
OF DRAWING CASH BEFORE THE WAR
BEGAN, THE MORE RISK YOU WERE
TAKING TO JUST DIE OF HUNGER IN
THE MIDDLE OF EUROPE IN THE 21st
CENTURY, WHICH IS
INCOMPREHENSIBLE TO ME AS I TELL
YOU, BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU
BECAUSE IT'S THE TRUTH RIGHT
NOW.
THE CITY IS STILL BESIEGED.
SO TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, THE
WAY TO SURVIVE WAS TO COOPERATE
WITH NEIGHBORS.
>> I WONDER HOW PEOPLE VIEW THIS
RUSSIAN ATTACK ON MARIUPOL.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS SAYING HE CAME
TO LIBERATE UKRAINIANS AND
ETHNIC RUSSIANS.
WHAT WERE THEY SAYING ABOUT HIM
IN THESE BOMB SHELTERS AS THEY
ENDURED DAYS OF SHELLING AND
BOMBING?
>> WELL, IT'S A COMPLICATED
QUESTION BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND SOME OF -- EVEN
MARIUPOL RESIDENTS WERE UNDER
VERY HEAVY RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA
INFLUENCE.
IF THEY HAVE BEEN CONSUMING ONLY
RUSSIAN MEDIA FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS, THEY WERE UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT THE RUSSIAN
SCREEN
SPRING WAS COMING AND THEY HAD
TO ENDURE THIS LIBERATION AND
EVERYTHING WAS FINE.
I DID HAVE NEIGHBORS LIKE THAT.
OBVIOUSLY WE DID NOT TALK, AND
WE DID NOT COOPERATE, AND I LET
THEM KNOW ABOUT MY VIEWS, AND WE
JUST STAYED AS FAR AWAY AS
POSSIBILITY.
BUT THAT WAS A MINORITY IN THE
BASEMENT.
THE MAJORITY WAS ABSOLUTELY
VICIOUSLY JUST -- THEY COULD NOT
BELIEVE THIS HAD HAPPENED.
THEY WERE NOT UNDERSTANDING WHAT
EXACTLY THEY WERE BEING
LIBERATED FROM, IF IT WAS
PEACEFUL LIFE, THAT WAS THE
CASE.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT THE MAIN FEELING WAS JUST
ANGER, JUST EXTREME ANGER AT THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE IN GENERAL WHO
LET IT HAPPEN IN THE LAST 30
YEARS.
>> LET ME ASK YOU NOW ABOUT YOUR
ESCAPE.
YOU WENT THROUGH, I UNDERSTAND,
11 RUSSIAN CHECKPOINTS TO GET
OUT OF THERE.
COULD YOU DESCRIBE THAT JOURNEY?
>> WE WENT THROUGH 2 UKRAINIAN
AND 16 RUSSIAN CHECKPOINTS, SO
18 TOTAL.
I MADE SURE TO COUNT JUST TO
HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER.
WE DROVE OUT ON THE MORNING,
7:00 A.M., ON THE 23rd OF MARCH.
I WAS THE ONE DRIVING ONE
VEHICLE JUST BECAUSE THERE WERE
NOT ENOUGH DRIVERS.
IT WAS PRIVATE CARS THAT WERE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE ENOUGH FOOL
TO GET US TO ZAPORIZHZHIA
BECAUSE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO BUY
FUEL ANYWHERE FROM MARIUPOL TO
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
AND I SAW -- I SAW RUSSIANS WITH
MY VERY EYES.
I MADE SURE TO NEVER SPEAK
UKRAINIAN WITH THEM BECAUSE THAT
WOULD ENDANGER MY LIFE AND THE
LIFE OF MY PASSENGERS.
BUT YOU JUST DRIVE PAST, YOU
KNOW, SUMMER CAMP YOU WENT TO,
YOUR HIGH SCHOOL, AND IT'S ALL
ABSOLUTELY DESTROYED AND BURNED
DOWN, NOT EVEN TANKS.
JUST LIKE PIECES AND REMNANTS OF
TANKS AND PRIVATE CARS AND
BODIES JUST LYING ON THE
STREETS.
AND YOU JUST HOPE AND PRAY, AND
YOU DON'T MAKE EYE CONTACT WITH
THE RUSSIANS, AND YOU JUST HOPE
THEY DON'T GO THROUGH YOUR
CAMERA SO YOU CAN GET SOME
EVIDENCE OUT OF IT.
IT'S JUST CONSTANTLY PRAY.
EVEN THE ATHEISTS I KNEW PRAYED
IN MY CAR.
>> YOU WEREN'T SPEAKING
UKRAINIAN IN FRONT OF THE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS SO YOU WOULDN'T
ENDANGER YOUR LIFE OR THE LIFE
OF YOUR PASSENGERS OF THE CAR
YOU WERE DRIVING.
AND YOU WERE JUST BASICALLY --
NOT CLOSING YOUR EYES.
YOU WERE DRIVING, BUT IT'S ONE
OF THOSE, LIKE, LET'S JUST DO
THIS.
LET'S JUST GO, PRAY, HOPE IT
GOES OKAY, AND YOU MADE IT.
AND WHEN YOU FINALLY MADE IT
OUT, WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> WHEN I MADE IT OUT, THERE WAS
A SPECIFIC MOMENT WHEN WE
APPROACHED A CHECKPOINT, AND THE
GUY SPOKE TO US IN UKRAINIAN
NEXT TO ZAPORIZHZHIA.
AND IT WAS THIS COMPLETE FEELING
OF RELIEF.
WE MADE IT, YOU KNOW, WE MADE
IT.
WE GOT CELL PHONE SERVICE.
WE GOT WI-FI.
EVERYBODY WAS TRYING TO MAKE
CALLS, AND WE WERE ESCORTED BY
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY INTO THE
CITY ITSELF BECAUSE IT WAS PAST
CURFEW.
IT FELT EERIE BECAUSE THE CITY
WAS ALSO IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CONFLICT.
IT WAS JUST NOT AS DESTROYED AS
MARIUPOL.
SO IT WAS PITCH DARK.
EVERYBODY WAS ABSOLUTELY
EXHAUSTED FROM THE RIDE.
BUT THE MAIN FEELING WAS JUST,
WE'RE BACK HOME.
>> WELL, I'M SO GLAD YOU MADE IT
OUT, AND I KNOW YOU'RE STILL
PROCESSING ALL OF THIS TRAUMA.
AND I WISH YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
ALL THE BEST.
ALIN